today's show is all about besties which
is why i'm here with cameron diaz and
ross matthias
and every single person in our audience
is a bestie
you know
i think there's nothing better than
trying something new with a bestie
remember when we did scuba diving with
sharks yeah or jumped out of an airplane
yeah
well drew and i were inspired by that we
tried something new
you may have seen a group called the
aqua lilies they're a group of
synchronized swimmers they were in the
coen brothers hail caesars justin
bieber's beauty and the beat or even
beyonce's black is king yeah they're
amazing uh well they really they had
their work cut out from when drew and i
tried to show up in their pool
take a look at this
we
love staff drew
[Applause]
so today you're going to be joining our
osu lilies team we are going to start by
teaching you guys how to do some basic
floating skills i have strong core
values but not as strong
[Music]
oh wow
[Music]
we're gonna turn and do a pinwheel with
our legs the way you turn it you just
like push the water away from you
basically i kayaked yeah
yes
i'm going to accept all of that applause
okay let's try this we want to turn
halfway so that our feet are facing out
where our head was before
make sense
yes sure and turn two three four five
six seven eight good job there we go
perfect you just keep turning i just
kept like paddling
paddling yeah okay
i think we're ready to learn the final
skill the back tuck somersault we are
all gonna disappear underwater at the
same time i'll try to do it slow
oh wow that was slow by the way
okay okay
[Laughter]
i'm like ross i don't have a core
by the way i just heard about a machine
where you sit in a chair and it reenacts
like thousands of key goals for women
who have had children and things like
that i'd still try it but
i feel like i need that chair right now
so quick question is there anything
easier than that
let's try an oyster
we are gonna start on our back and then
we're gonna fold and disappear under
water so you're saying the key is to
just sink done
oh that's fun it makes my voice even
more annoying
i'm gonna help you a little bit just
just really just shut me down okay
honestly do i look cute though
focus ladies okay ready
one two three go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
drop your butt and get your knees up and
before you know it it feels like you
could do anything okay like that's the
key move all right and then you're
enough about your dating life
circle up
splash
five six seven eight
drop our right ear and we're gonna kick
around kick two three four five six
seven eight i think i had the count
wrong this is quick
are we ready to do this from the top
[Music]
well that's one way to cool off i think
ross and i found a new pool party trick
and we want to thank the aqua lilies who
are such good friends and so supportive
to each other as an amazing group of
women they're so capable and cool
they're synchronized you guys that's
like
like the like next level best friend
yeah and can i just say drew and i are
naturals thank you so much
[Music]
you